[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce paradis tropical à qui
les au parc de Beauval ce lieu
formidable participe à la préservation
d'une grande variété d'espèces et
derrière un mot bien sûr les girafes
il y avait des girafes derrière le
quoi non moi je balance pas moi
je suis pas une poucave jamais je te
dirai elle est là elle est plus là basta
ne cherche pas bon
en tout cas on va aller voir les girafes
et rencontrer Alexandre un soigneur qui
a eu la chance d'assister à une
naissance la naissance de Maïwenn un
petit girafon séquence émotion j'ai déjà
envie de pleurer
[Musique]
et on va la fâché Noé
Alex il y a combien d'espèces ici qui
sont dans cet enclos là on a une mixité
d'espèces qu'on va retrouver à l'état
sauvage tout ensemble donc là d'abord on
a les autruches ensuite à côté on a des
hypotragues et à côté on a les girafes
et encore après les girafes nous avons
les zèbres et les rhinocéros que j'ai
jamais vu une girafe aussi près bon là
il y a 7 ou 8 girafes alors là il y a 8
girafes on a quatre femelles adultes
trois jeunes et un mal adulte qui est
notre mal reproducteur alors toi tu as
eu la chance d'assister à une naissance
la naissance de Maïwenn est-ce que tu
peux nous en dire plus et bien c'était
au mois de février la mise-bas a
commencé dans les alentours de 10h30 et
vers 14h30 il était sorti voilà il s'est
relevé et puis tout allait bien et c'est
parti quoi tu vas aller nourrir tu vas
t'en approcher ou pas c'est ça là on va
aller les nourrir donc on va leur mettre
une partie de leur ration du soir et
donc ça mange quoi du foin de l'herbe à
l'état sauvage ça mange des feuilles et
sinon il mange de la luzerne plus un peu
des légumes et ce qu'on va leur donner
tout à l'heure qui s'appelle de la pulpe
de betteraves c'est en complément
alimentaire on a pulpe de betteraves
ont bon goût c'est 4 étoiles c'est des
herbivores allez on est parti
on y va suivez le saut suivez le saut
je vais essayer
[Musique]
et c'est moi qui ai préparé ça j'ai mis
2 heures de préparation alors je vous
donne la recette tofu tu mixes tu
rajoutes du bon colis ensuite tu
rajoutes des graines de sésame succulent
non succulent alors je vois il y en a il
y a une girafe qui est toute seule
là-bas isolé bon elle se fait plaisir
elle mange comme il faut pourquoi elle
est toute seule là-bas celle-là alors
cette girafe qui est isolée toute seule
là-bas c'est Momo notre mal reproducteur
on préfère que la nuit soit séparée pour
qu'il n'embête pas les femelles si
jamais il a envie de se reproduire pour
que tout soit calme que les filles
puissent dormir tranquillement on les
sépare
tu penses aux histoires de zizi au lieu
de faire des études au lieu de faire la
physique-chimie mon père il lui dirait
ça je suis sûr mon père même avec une
girafe faut faire la physique chimie et
donc là dans quel état elles sont elles
sont calmes elles sont elles sont
apaisées elles ont un peu peur elles
sont craintives comment tu les sens toi
qui les connaît très bien si on fait le
tour de toutes nos girafes elles sont
toutes calmes et apaisées et on va dire
qu'il y en a une seule qui est vraiment
curieuse et qui se demande ce qui se
passe actuellement c'est Maïwenn et ce
type de girafe on y retrouve en Afrique
que en Afrique exactement tu es
magnifique ma chérie et franchement je
tiens à te dire bienvenue dans Kamini en
roue libre merci le plaisir est pour moi
ils sont beaucoup plus polis que les
zèbres et les autres